final game against
grand master v dock that's um
boris great chef so
rated 2700 not only here but also
the feeder rating list but not quite
sure
maybe he had some some drinks already
played h4h5 usually he plays normal
openings and
in blitz
yeah black black just is clearly better
already
but well he's really a great blitz
player so
it's nothing
nothing i decided yet
yeah he wants to um finally
develop his knight i think
i need to um be cautious here in regards
to the time because um it's also graded
bullet and
so i need to
need to stay stay
quickly don't spend too much time
d4 then he's got knight b5 maybe then
knight d5
yeah okay
and to play really play quickly here
yeah needs to
how do i continue of course black is
black is fine here
queen to c5 maybe
this will also prepare a long castle
yeah e5 but this is just a self pin i
can play
bishop d5 for something
bishop d5 is also possible now
or do i have something something even
better
queen c5 is also good
yeah basically black is just winning but
um
need to still be cautious
yeah c7 is hanging
what do i play g6 open the position up
g6 rook c7 and a bishop c7
rook g8 maybe maybe he's got some stupid
move like bishop b8
but i could cover this i want to open
the g
file
let's try this
really need to make sure not to fall too
far behind on the clock
he will be very quick at the end
yeah he's got this strange man i
wouldn't i have this
is some weird answer uh maybe rook d1
now
rook d1
yeah maybe i got myself into trouble
here
unnecessarily
okay
trying to use the g file quickly
okay let's get rid of this to not get
mated
yeah of course i should i should have
more
it's still better for me but
rook c5
rook g5
rook g8 now does he have some great
discovery then
with with the knight
or just f6 f6 maybe
it's got f4 but i can take e5 i can take
e5
i didn't see this move
okay wow
yeah this was totally unnecessary to get
this
kind of complications
but still maybe it's fine
bishop c6 now bishop c6
and capture on f3
h4 then winning a piece okay prevented
this
maybe i can get rid of one rook to make
this somewhat more simple to play
yeah i've got the bishop pair and an
extra pawn only a very
very untidy pawn structure
yeah okay i should have prevented this
time warning yeah yeah i know
if it takes rook a5 then getting this
back
check check
check check
check
b5
yeah of course this is very drawish
check
the extra pawn doesn't really mean much
yeah he will play on time every position
i know
pretty sure
ah this was a stupid move
check
check
check
check check check
check check
check check
check yeah okay now it's even making
progress here because i don't have any
time
it was completely drawn the joke end
game everything before
check
yeah yeah of course this was forfeits on
time completely unnecessary
it was just just too slow at the end
and of course i should have just won the
game when i had a huge advantage
to not even get into this
but um
yeah this position is just just a
complete win
and i don't um i shouldn't shouldn't
have gotten into this
this time issues at all
maybe just rook d7 or something yeah
this wasn't too bad
i was always fine i think
black is better all the way
i'm just going to going through here
quickly
yeah this of course is um now
um somewhat drawing check check check
check this is just just a total draw
check check
yeah okay what can you do
okay this was the final game for today's
session i need to
um go to the supermarket really to
to to get some food okay thanks for
watching and um i'll
do some more videos the next couple of
days
see ya